- [Announcer] Folks give it up
for the host of today's show,
Jay Leno.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat jazz music)
- Hi everybody.
Thank you very much.
Welcome to The Kelly Clarkson Show.
I am not Kelly.
I am Jay leno.
This is my second time doing it.
You know,
it's the holiday season and
Kelly's taken a personal time,
with her kids do some
shopping and all kinda stuff.
So she asked grandpa Jay
to come in and kinda,
kinda take over here for a little bit.
So I certainly appreciate that.
I've got a lot of guys here today, good.
Hey guys, you like shopping guys?
- [Men] Yeah (cheering)
- Really?
Oh, you're lying.
You don't like shopping.
(audience laughing)
You know something.
My wife said to me the other day.
"You know, every time a light
bulb blows in this house,
you go to the supermarket
you buy one bulb.
Can you go down to Home Depot or Lowe's
or one of these places,
just get a box of."
I said, "You know, honey,
that's a great idea."
So I go over here to Home Depot
and I'm walking down
the electric department.
"ah Mr Leno."
"Hey how you doing?"
I said, "you got the bunch
of assorted lights bulbs?"
He goes, "I'll get you our Acarno pack."
Okay.
So he comes out with a box about this big.
I said, "that's perfect."
It's got a bunch of light bulbs then said,
"how much is this?"
Says $118.
(audience laughing)
yeah, I said, "$118?
That's a lot of money for
a couple of light bulbs."
Guy goes, "These are LED bulbs, Mr Leno,
these bulbs last 15 years.
I said," you know, I'm
71 years old, okay."
(audience laughing)
"The odds of me seeing 86.
tenuous at best.
I don't want to drop dead at 76,
lay in a coffin for 10 years.
Knowing some Yahoo's flicking lights
on and off on my dime, okay.
I want the bulbs that
die, when I die, yeah."
(audience clapping)
Let me ask the guys here.
Some of you ever do this?
You make a mistake,
a shopping mistake early in your marriage.
You pay for it the rest of your life.
Okay, for example,
I am not allowed to buy
furniture for the house
by myself anymore, okay.
I made one mistake.
My wife and I got married.
I said, "let's get a couch,
lets get a used couch"
" I don't want a used couch.
You know what filthy things,"
but I am like, "fine Okay".
So I'm, every couch has
hundreds of thousands.
So I go,
I go past this place on Third and Olympic
locally made furniture, couches from $250.
I go, it's fantastic.
I said, "where's your $260 couch?"
guy goes, "it's the one in the window."
I look at it.
You know, it's got a wood
frame and cushions, no springs,
but cushions, you know.
So i said, "well this good."
I said, "when you can deliver."
"we deliver it tomorrow."
I'll give the man the money.
I go, "honey, I bought a
couch, no problem," You know.
So they bring the couch in.
You've got the big cushions,
you know. we sit on it and it,
it doesn't really go down.
You know, you know what I mean?
Like sitting on a beach ball or something
and the guy says, "oh no,
you give it seven to 10 days.
It will conform to your body type."
So my wife and I try to
watch TV on this thing.
So I have to, after like five
or six days, my wife goes,
"you know, this is really uncomfortable."
I said, "well, let me unzip the cushions.
I'll take out some of the foam
and that'll make it more compliant."
I unzipped the thing.
First thing I pull out three
pairs of men's underpants.
Just old underpants, then some socks.
My wife says, "its some
homeless guys underpants,
get that out of here"
I go, "honey that" "no
I don't that disgusting.
get it, throw it out throw it out."
So I dragged my couch out to
the street, my brand new couch,
I leave it on the street.
It's out there for two days.
On the second day, (growling) I look up,
I see coyotes with underpants,
running up and down the street.
(audience clapping)
Anyway listen.